three three points five assists so far
going to work on bass and should hear
her Brandon bass out on an island nobody
helped the little flow of different ways
what this team is about the Showtime
Lakers averaged 115 points
[Applause]
Curry's man doesn't give help too late
so hilar Ulis is checked in he's in just
a guard step and Durant's breaking down
the lane and the POW dead but Kevin
Durant with the spike of the early
season here what a second quarter come
out of the timeout draymond Green comes
up with a steal curry night big on the
baseline moodini move tight ropes the
baseline the ballet up and under takes
the bump from behind and the finesse
with the finish he went he knows where
he is as curry hit another three
[Applause]
NBA record 13 trees the next game 13 of
17 from me on the earth and 46 and the
boy
[Applause]
we'll get the frame
[Applause]
he thinks he has a free one that's why
he comes to a jump stop and that enabled
Kevin Durant to have time to block the
shot curry answers with a three
just how you brought up
water scoring in a variety of ways
[Applause]
best defensive season he's ever had
you're seeing his full complement of
skills and he met Len at the top with
the block
Kabaddi well he's beautiful with that
cross over and around bogdanovich and
then you lose group Brook Lopez how
important is it he sets the guy up he'll
sit right there okay how he did that off
the dribble he was actually apologizing
to rant on the play saying that should
have got you the ball open now you're
going to see him doing a little shimmy
off the rim curry has time three seconds
curry from half-court
[Applause]
objection I want to go for the East
[Applause]
time heals all wounds right here
hopefully I know it's only warpath but
we could have a little peace between
Westbrook and Durant
[Applause]
the other night I think he used the
variation of that can beat them but I
think they can give them a good a good
push courier with the fake on feeling
Brown drills it
we've got the rookie up in the air put
them in the blender here Jeff
great shot fake out to the pickup and
the three at the buzzer
that's for you young fellow
[Applause]
something special tonight within three
all over less this year I don't know
what he did here two men go up in the
air I think they're gonna come down on
him and he eludes them going underneath
with the left Houdini
[Applause]
oh goodness
[Applause]
at that size that skill and then rips it
down Kevin Durant and the open floor is
a sight to behold
typical children
[Applause]
the panic doesn't rush plays the
tremendous pace curry draws the foul
gets the roll and will head to the
free-throw line
well Murray gets his body into curry
curry with remarkable played like 12
games in 47 games 40 Sunday 3 to Durant
by the high scorer Kevin Durant
[Applause]
durant on the pull-up at the buzzer
Kevin Durant knocks down the three
they'll review it but he got it off in
time a very deep position they're
hurrying with the rebound
whether fortunate Drummond is not
scoring yet bounce he pushes it ahead
and there's nothing small about this
small forward gets on the wing and the
backscratcher with the right hand all
the screens to go away maybe crossover
jump Virg
six seconds of defense on the rookie
Lonzo ball KD creates for himself and
drops it home but with six seconds left
no timeout and ball came back the other
way he couldn't stop to ran on one end a
[Music]
couple that with klay Thompson getting
the rep is Durant shakes
[Applause]
first career three of three from three
this one got him to 20,000 career points
[Music]
with the triple give him seven down the
hatch ago the center ants key had it
stolen by Nick Young a two-on-one for
Golden State up high and down hard for
Kevin Durant timeout Washington Brooks's
frustration this is a sixth turnover we
still have over four minutes to go in
this pass to low victory recovers shot
clock winding down so he's gonna have to
put it up launches it up chocolate Steph
Curry Hanlon recognized the clock is
blowing down it actually looked
beautiful in the end my goodness mama
there goes that man he's been a nice
boost for Toronto he's talented now
offensively and just goes into the body
of Larry Nance
if you feel again yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but who hit sell and they watch Markieff
Morris well then oh boy you're right
because Bradley Beal came right under
Stefon courage
[Applause]
to play work ends I ran off the good
defense
chosen out Iguodala said I'll give it up
to you if you have an angle
[Applause]
[Music]
he now has the Warriors are down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is why we love basketball Kady
didn't even have the ball in his hand
correctly
he wasn't even set everyone knew he was
going to shoot this ball that's why he
wants it at the end of games are you
kidding me give him the best shooter in
the world stop this pumped up my bad
walk down to seven
Greymon what to set the screen down to
three look how far they push the battery
down the lane for the
they got a mismatch
where the settle furs over here know
what he knows he could get by a bigger
man overextending was Harold too much
precious curry just used that pressure
against montrezl harrell and beat him to
the bathroom the other thing is if you
stick a jumper with seven seconds left
or something the Clippers will have an
opportunity step bled the clock this
point five he knew what he was doing
comes curry here's a long one Stefan
curry nine of ten twenty three points
finding should know that he's going to
take this as the clock winds down to the
halftime break that is what he does
[Applause]
[Applause]
Russell was the cross
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is how the rest of the league
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
with the left hand curry three-quarter
court
beats the buzzer with a Fenton three for
his first triple of the quarter not
worrying about his staff I'm gives
himself a chance good for him
now four seconds left you need to do it
again curry for three
they dead foul and they'll go to double
overtime Oh her is really really there's
one dance left he is pointing to the lot
I think Ryan Saunders by two learned a
lesson and on but you can follow them
right there pushing you can just grab
him after he's dribbling the balls on
the floor like that and instead curry
stripes of three oh what a clutch shot
[Applause]
Durant
long three Kevin Durant with a chance
for a four-point play from several feet
beyond the arc and already this his
second foul and is clearly contact
the rant 18 points five rebounds what's
up you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content